d'abord et ça se rejoint évidemment le
pass vaccinale examiné par les sénateurs
des sénateurs qui recevait dès
aujourd'hui le ministre de la santé
sujet signé flora sauvage si la majorité
de droite et du centre du sénat soutient
le principe du pass vaccinale en
commission les sénateurs ont souhaité
fixer ses modalités pratiques et le
limiter dans le temps on pense à la date
du 31 juillet date de validité ou date
avant laquelle le gouvernement devra
revenir devant le parlement pour des
explications sur le tas sur le passage
final on peut imaginer aussi qu'ils le
soient applicables de façon peu
diversifiées sur le territoire selon un
haut niveau de pandémie selon un
amendement du rapporteur philippe bas le
pass vaccinale pourrait s'appliquer si
le nombre d'hospitalisations est
supérieure à 10 milles au niveau
national et dans les départements ou
moins de 80 % de la population est
vaccinée ou si le taux d'incidence est
élevé face aux réserves des sénateurs le
ministre a tenté de rassurer une
évidence mais parfois les évidences
doivent être rappelés tous ceux qui ces
outils de passes sanitaire de tasses
vaccinale le jour on en a plus besoin
le jour où nous sommes plus sous la
menace permanente de nouveaux variants
nous en passeront avec beaucoup de
plaisir mais en quoi le pass vaccinale
va-t-il limiter la propagation du virus
alors que 300000 contamination ou lieu
actuellement chaque jour les sénateurs
s'interrogent sur l'efficacité d'un tel
outil on parle exclusivement d'impasse
vaccinale qui en réalité pour la plupart
des français déjà rentré dans les moeurs
et face à une flambée sans précédent de
l'épidémie
on ne peut pas dire que le pass
vaccinale souhaite une mesure
répondant à une urgence sanitaire le
pass vaccinale vous dites est ce que ça
s'intègre dans l'urgence sanitaire avant
même que le pass vaccinale soit adopté
les effets sont déjà visibles puisque la
simple évocation du pass vaccinale a
fait bondir le nombre de primo
vaccination dans notre pays 230 milles
le sénat examinera mardi après midi en
séance publique le texte modifié en
commission sur la question liminaire les
sénateurs veulent aller plus loin que
les députés en relevant de 16 à 18 ans
l'âge à partir duquel le pass vaccinale
pourrait être demandée pour les
activités scolaires ou périscolaires
sa phase finale le gouvernement espère
donc qu'il sera applicable dès le tout
début de la semaine prochaine mais sous
quelle forme avec qu'elle garde fous on
en débat tout de suite je vous présente
mes invités florence lassarade bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes pédiatre sénatrice l
ère de la gironde et secrétaire de la
commission des affaires sociales au
sénat bruno m'égare ban bonsoir bonsoir
chef du service de réanimation de
l'hôpital lariboisière vincent brun
garde bonsoir bienvenue avocat en droit
pénal et libertés fondamentales vous
publiez
revendiquons le droit à la désobéissance
et aux éditions fayard avec nous en
duplex
xavier iacovelli et sénateurs l hérault
m des hauts-de-seine membres du groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant bonsoir à
vous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et bien sûr comme chaque
lundi et chaque mercredi mathieu
croissandeau de soveria liste politique
peut-être un tour de table assez rapide
pour commencer pour savoir si vous êtes
favorable ou non au principe de passes
vaccinale j'aimerais vous entendre les
uns et les autres assez rapidement parce
qu'ensuite on va on va débattre florence
lassarade bien qu'il arrive un petit peu
tard ce se passe vaccinale enfin c'est
un petit peu du contretemps on aurait pu
en discuter dès novembre ou décembre
pourquoi pas moi comme médecin je peux
difficilement aller contre et puis les
hôpitaux sont saturés menti c'est pas
les services de réanimation qui sont les
plus et plus
menacé ce sont aussi des services de
pneumologie de médecine ou les soignants
manque donc ça serait un mauvais signal
vis-à-vis des soignants d'être contre se
passe d' accident c'est mon point de vue
renault mégane oui je suis favorable
en fait c'est l'aboutissement du pass
sanitaire le pass and i ter avait laissé
un peu de temps pour ce qui était encore
hésitant se faire vacciner à réfléchir à
on va dire s'informer
récolter les les réponses à leurs doutes
éventuels maintenant il faut passer à la
phase suivante un outil de protection
supplément est un outil qui pousse à la
vaccination à nouveau il ne protège pas
contre les contaminations il pousse à la
vaccination
environ 40000 primo vaccination et
surtout 600 milles par jour le troisième
dose dose de rappel et donc je crois que
l'idée du passo axonale permet à toutes
ces personnes qu'elle y croit ou pas d'y
aller et évidemment c'est une mesure de
santé publique donc je suis favorable
vincent lagaf' vous vous revendiquez je
le rappelle c'est petit de votre d'élite
de livres le droit à la désobéissance
sur le pass vaccine qu'on peut vraiment
avoir une interrogation sur la
proportionnalité d'un tel outil on a
demandé il ya quelques années maintenant
presque deux ans au français de se
vacciner parce que ça limiter la
contagion et puis aujourd'hui on demande
encore de vacciner sauf que les données
scientifiques on a aujourd'hui en tout
cas en possession permettent de voir que
finalement les effets et concerne en
tout cas la contagion sont extrêmement
limités que ça pourrait éventuellement
avoir des effets mais uniquement
concilier concernant les cas graves donc
je crois que l'audit quoi passer de l'or
c'était le début d'épidémie en deux ans
elle débute pas encore le vaccin mais
assez assez rapidement il ya eu déjà le
débat dans son pays sur 7 sur cette
vaccination obligatoire en tout cas sur
l'adhésion du grand public à la
vaccination et je crois que la question
qui se pose c'est vérité mancelle de
proportionnalité et 700 se dire au
regard de l'atteinte portée à son ombre
de liberté à la fois individuelle et
collective individuelle parce que ça
porte notamment atteinte à la liberté
d'aller et venir que ça vous prive
notamment d'accès à certains lieux est
ce que véritablement vous êtes face à un
outil qui proportionne ou moi je
considère que vous considérez que non et
on va évidemment détailler vos arguments
tout à l'heure xavier iacovelli pourquoi
vous y êtes j'imagine favorable
j'y suis favorable parce que je pense
effectivement que c'est un moyen ce
n'est pas le seul moyen mais c'est un
moyen de lutter contre l'épidémie est en
tout cas de faire en sorte que les
français puissent se vacciner accéder à
la vaccination et les contraindre au pas
mais en tout cas accéder à la
vaccination et on sait très bien
aujourd'hui que la vaccination est un
des seuls moyens de lutter contre
l'épidémie puisque ça diminue la
contamination qu'on le veuille ou non en
tout cas les anti vaccins utilise le
contraire mais on voit bien que ça
diminue même si ça n'empêche pas la
contamination mais ça surtout ça
supprime quasi la totalité des effets
graves de cette de cette pandémie et
donc je pense que il faut continuer à
inciter les français à y aller un site
est également les non-vaccinés
franchir le pas et dont on voit bien que
ce pass vaccinale a déjà fait ses
preuves rien qu en l'annonçant puisqu'on
a des primo à des des primes au pardon
vacciner quasiment tous les jours
l'argument que me les a senti qu'on
irait vers entonnait
au sénat cet après midi mathieu on
entendre les premières réactions c'est
peut-être aussi et d'abord un outil de
politique c'est un outil de politique
moi je trouve qu'il pose une question
quand même pourquoi on déclare pas 500
obligatoire ou alors je sais bien
qu'elle ait débat comment on fait une
fois le fait de dire que c'est
obligatoire les gens n'ont plus de choix
globalement il est quand même un effet
psychologique quand c'est obligatoire
vous le faites et je trouve bizarre
qu'on avant toute une série d'outils
pour compliquer la vie de ceux qui ne se
soumettrait pas quelque chose qui n'est
pas obligatoire plutôt que de décréter
une bonne fois pour toutes que c'est
obligatoire oui pourquoi on passe pas
par cette phase là d'ailleurs avec
100000 à thouars vous êtes plutôt
favorable moi j'y étais favorable il ya
un moment mais bon maintenant on est un
peu à la traîne concernant toutes ces
mesures on a l'impression que ces cds
ces nouveaux événements pour faire
parler ou de me sauver hre en outre moi
je pense que si on l'avait fait cela
aurait été bien antérieur on en parlait
cet été ou à la rentrée septembre donc
vous dites c'est déjà trop c'est trop
tard pour une vaccination le paradoxe
est que ce n arriva à vacciner sur un
variant qui il faut l'expliquer aussi et
paraît beaucoup plus mineures dansé
dansé et fait donc oui mais pour le
grand public comprendre ça c'est quelque
chose de pas grave on a discuté de la
vaccination des enfants d'ailleurs il
n'ya pas très longtemps
quelque chose qui est pas grave pourquoi
est ce que j'irai moins vacciner on le
voit d'ailleurs moi je vois autour de
moi quand j'en discute ceux qui sont
aussi la vaccination ou qu'ils n'ont pas
vraiment envie d'y aller un thomas
franchement hostile c'est relativement
gêne pas les étudiants parce qu'ils en
ont besoin pour leur vie quotidienne
mais d'une population de 2 30 40 ans
très peu vulnérables à la maladie et qui
voit pas trop l'intérêt je pensais une
discussion de plus ça va matthieu
croissandeau xavier iacovelli quand vous
avez proposé la vaccia option
obligatoire qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors moi j'ai toujours dit et je les
dis d'ailleurs sur votre plateau il y a
quelques semaines avant avant la coupure
des fêtes de noël j'étais j'ai toujours
été favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire sauf qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne nous propose et on est aujourd'hui en
incapacité d'avoir des sanctions réelles
pour la mise en application de cette
vaccination obligatoire et c'est pour ça
qu'on est passés par un passe vaccinale
pour inciter contraindre un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens à aller se
faire vacciner et indirectement c'est
une obligation vaccinale mais je pense
aussi qu'il ya un problème de notre
personnel politique moi je vois un pays
qui m'est cher aussi l'italie où ils ont
imposé la vaccination aux plus de 50 ans
il ya la quasi-unanimité delà des modes
et des forces politiques quasiment
limitée et on peut pas dire que l'italie
n'est pas un pays latin un pays qui a le
sang chaud comme on peut dire et donc
c'est même pas question de 2,2 c'est
vraiment une question de posture
politique de nos oppositions et quand je
vois le cinéma que les républicains ont
fait à l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière en repoussant sur trois jours
en tout les débats alors que ça aurait
pu être fait en une journée une journée
et une nuit sincèrement qu'on nous dise
maintenant il fallait le faire avant il
fallait prendre deux c'est trop tard
pour l'obligation vaccinale des jeux
j'en ris gens rient jaune mais janvier
un mot de réponse ne serait-ce que c'est
une question de présence dans
l'hémicycle tout simplement ce type de
vote on peut pas on veut pas dire que
c'est la faute des républicains
maintenant s'il est si les députés
étaient à la buvette et à la buvette bon
allez on va pas revenir sur 7 sur cette
crise de la semaine passée je voudrais
qu'on est con on écoute le porte parole
du gouvernement gabriela talent qui
alors je les dis en ouverture de ce
débat
le gouvernement espère une application
dès le tout début de la semaine
prochaine donc lundi 17 et peut-être
dans les deux jours qui suivent écouter
le porte parole nous visons un examen du
texte qui s'achèverait cette semaine
donc la semaine qui vient et ensuite
tout dépendra de si le texte est déférée
au conseil constitutionnel ou pas mais
en tout état de cause on vise au plus
tard une application du pas l'acte final
dans les premiers jours de la semaine du
17 janvier voilà c'est notre objectif
encore une fois c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
un petit décalage peut être de deux
jours mais vous voyez pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez une coalition paquet
rennes l air france insoumise pour
bloquer l'examen du texte à l'assemblée
nationale bon on fait de la politique
sanitaire et aussi de la politique
politique matthieu croissandeau est ce
que vous comprenez l'urgence vincent
brun garde on comprenait d'urgence au
début les sanitaires mais je crois que
après deux ans de crise sanitaire ce que
nous on a besoin aussi ce débat de
débats contradictoires moi ce qui me
stupéfait c'est que lorsqu'on entend un
porte parole du gouvernement qui prévoit
des gens la mise en application du pass
vaccinale alors même que les débats au
sein du parlement qui est sensé qui
était censé encore être un
contre-pouvoir on ne sont pas terminées
c'est comme si finalement on admettait
le fait que de toute façon on savait que
la mesure allait de voter et se coûte
que coûte et moi je pense que il y avait
ri tellement je le disais tout à l'heure
un débat sur la proportionnalité au
regard aussi de la transparence la
sombre deux venaient parce que il ya des
éléments qu'il faut quand même expliquer
aux personnes je disais tout à l'heure
par rapport au fait que c'est un parce
qu'ils ne permettraient pas de limiter
la contagion et de l'humanisme même
manière ont mentionné tout à l'heure le
cas de l'italie avec une mesure qui
concernerait les personnes âgées de plus
de 50 ans qui effectivement peuvent être
elles plus sujettes à des formes graves
lorsqu'elles sont elles sont contaminés
donc c'est peut-être ce débat qui
devrait exister davantage qu'une mesure
complètement généralisée mais
attentatoires pour le collectif
l'argument de bruno meyer banksters
était de dire que finalement l'annoncent
ça a provoqué un afflux de vaccination
est donc ça limite la contamination il
ya cet effet cet effet réel vous pouvez
pas nier mais en tant qu'allemand du
vote d'un pass vaccinale et d'un cran
supplémentaire entre une femme et je
raisonne pas en termes politiques en
terme d'utilisation qui est fait ou non
d'une politique d'annoncés d'une
politique d'affichage la vraie question
c'est savoir est-ce que se passe-t-il
iter encore une fois répond à l'objectif
de proportionnalité et vous avez
notamment d'ailleurs le défenseur des
droits qui s'est exprimé sur ce sujet et
qui a exprimé des interrogations assez
sévère et qui a alerté le gouvernement
vous aviez aussi la cncdh qui même dans
un avis en 2020 mettait que 20 indiqué
que la sueur près la pression dans les
hôpitaux était aussi lié à des choix
gouvernementaux qui avaient été faits
notamment concernant la haine des
politiques publiques et le nombre de
lits en réanimation
bruno mais garde un aspect est une
urgence effectivement parce que
florence lassarade le disais tout à
l'heure c'est cette eau mikron
finalement on voit si j'ai bien compris
peu de malades en réanimation j'aurais
est ce que c'est le cas dans votre
hôpital alors j'allais dire oui à une
urgence avec 300 milles contamination
par jour 1 % des patients finissent à
l'hôpital donc faites les calculs
rapidement vous avez à peu près de
l'ordre de 2000 nouveaux entrants chaque
jour en hospitalisation il ya 150
patients par jour qui rentrent en
réanimation donc c'est pas anodin
heureusement pour nous c'est
probablement un peu moins que ce qu'on a
connu dans les autres vagues mais c'est
quand même important il faut rappeler
que le variant delta circulent toujours
qu'il est responsable de from
extrêmement grave nous avons chez nous
aujourd'hui dans les rénovations de
l'assistance publique plus de la moitié
des patients et en lac ou vite qui sont
là depuis plusieurs semaines à moi qui
sont intubés ventilés et qui sont en
train de lutter pour leur survie environ
200 personnes meurent chaque jour de
causes vide mais bien alors même c'est
ça le point important on a un moyen
parfaitement efficace pour éviter en
tout cas pour réduire très
significativement tout ça parce qu'à
nouveau la très grosse majorité des
patients en réanimation en
hospitalisation sont des personnes non
vaccinées donc le vaccin alors à mars il
faut répéter rien sur le maïs le vaccin
ça marche contre les formes graves alors
c'est vrai que au micron crée aussi
d'autres types de problèmes parce
qu'évidemment il contamine des personnes
vaccinées il peut on va dire faire des
compensées des personnes âgées fragiles
même vacciné mais pour autant le socle
des personnes les plus graves reste des
personnes non vaccinées et qui sont
contaminés en animations avec des formes
plus monique mai et alors qu'il essaye
de parler puisque vous parlez de
d'opportunités en fête ou de
proportionnalité mais est ce que vous
vous dites c'est peut-être déjà trop
tard parce que le pic de sept wagons
mikron ou au micron il est prévu pour
quand et finalement est ce que ce pass
vaccinale va pas arriverez vous voyez ce
que je veux dire alors qu'on sera dans
une décrue de la vague omicron vous avez
raison on va dire la vaccination est
utile on va dire un mois et demi à peu
près avant
de pouvoir qu'on être confronté au virus
malgré tout le fait d'avoir reçu une
dose est quand même mieux que d'en avoir
zéro le fait d'avoir eu reçu deux doses
est quand même mieux que de n'avoir 0 et
3 doses c'est optimale mais évidemment
toutes les personnes qui se vaccinent
aujourd'hui pendant au moins un mois et
demi il faut qu'elle se considère comme
non vaccinés donc se protège alors le
pico mikron est prévu probablement vers
la mi janvier en termes de contamination
puis voilà une décrue alors on connaît
pas la vitesse avec laquelle la décrue à
ceux observés
qui va probablement s'étaler sur le mois
de février il faut savoir on a toujours
d'une vague delta qui sévit il descend
certes mais qui est quand même encore
responsable de ne pas loin de quarante
mille contamination jours donc ça reste
encore extrêmement élevé avec des
entrées en réanimation toujours de
patients contaminés par delta donc tout
ça fait évidemment on est dans situation
on va dire extrêmement sérieuse encore
est le fait de se vacciner maintenant
c'est aussi de se protéger contre de
nouvelles vagues car personne
aujourd'hui n'est capable de dire qu'il
n'y aura plus de circulation virale
après qu'il n'y aura plus de vagues
épidémiques bien sûr qu'il y en aura les
virus ne vont pas disparaître de la
surface de la planète même si on peut
espérer ans avec l'hypothèse la plus
favorable qui ne vont s'atténuer en
termes de virulence mais rien ne le dit
rien de le dire mais alors ça propose la
question et je me retourne de nouveau
verre ou deux
un état d'exception parce que ça fait
effectivement quasiment deux années que
ça dure complètement et d'ailleurs au
départ il y avait une discussion sur le
point de savoir si on devait ou non
introduire un nouvel état d'urgence on a
décidé de dupliquer ce qui était prévu
par la ville 1955 et de créer un nouvel
état d'urgence et l'idée l'état
d'urgence c'est d'offrir des pouvoirs
dérogatoire notamment gouvernement
notamment au premier ministre pour faire
face à une situation immédiate sauf
qu'en fait ça fait déjà plus de deux ans
donc que nous connaissons cette crise et
qu'on a le sentiment que nous ne
remettons pas en cause le fait qu' il ya
une défaillance objective et qui doit
amener un contradictoires qui doit
amener un débat avec l'ensemble des
contre-pouvoirs puisque on voit bien
avec la persistance de l'épidémie que de
fait peut-être que ce qu'on a mis en
oeuvre étaient pas forcément opérant et
moi sur les skis mais ce qui me
stupéfait quand même notamment cette
question de dudu passe du poste axial
celles effectivement en plus si vous
voulez en termes de cohérence sa gêne
encore plus parce que on vient
introduire une optique est une
obligation vaccinale
implicitement obligatoire alors même que
nous sommes face invariants qui est un
invariant particuliers même par rapport
à la forme première de la cocaïne ce qui
non seulement ajoute si je peux dire en
appréciation politique de la mesure qui
est prise et ce qui trouble de façon
considérable en cohérence alors est-ce
que la noce de ce pass vaccinale est ce
que les les propos du président de la
république également dans le temps chez
nous que nos confrères du quotidien le
parisien aujourd'hui en france cette
remobilisation des anti vaccins qu'on a
vu le week-end dernier et puis et puis
une image que voudrait vous montrer
c'est une image du jour et ça elle
rentrer dans ce débat parce qu'on est
sur l'acceptabilité aussi du pass
vaccinale dont vous allez discuter
demain et mercredi au sénat c'est
l'agression voyez les images de du
député les mêmes de saint pierre et
miquelon stéphane claireaux ils
attendaient devant chez lui des des
antilles passe pour discuter et vous le
voyez il a reçu son des halles c'est du
goémon mais aussi selon députés un galet
qui lui est passé à quelques centimètres
du visage là on est vraiment dans dans
de la violence pure contre un
représentant
des des citoyens c'est mercredi il faut
il faut mettre le contexte c'est
mercredi que le pass sanitaire doit être
saint-pierre-et-miquelon donc il ya
certainement à un lien est-ce que vous
l'a liée aussi aux propos du président
de la république vincent lagarde en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que moi je peux
comprendre qu'ils aient un sentiment
d'exaspération décembre de citoyens
aussi parce que il faut bien mesurer ce
qu'on demande depuis plusieurs années à
savoir non seulement des contraintes et
des conséquences économiques que on
peine aujourd'hui à mesurer aussi des
conséquences psychologiques qu'on va
devoir mesurer dans les prochains mois
en revanche ce qui est bien certain
c'est que absolument rien ne justifie la
violence rien ne justifie ce qu'on vient
lorsqu'on vient de voir mais est ce que
ça montre aussi c'est que ya peut-être
aussi une défaillance notamment du
parlement qui fait qu'il n'est pas
suffisamment représentatifs de toutes
les expressions représentatif de toutes
les expressions et qu' il ya de nombreux
français qui ont le sentiment
aujourd'hui que leur parole n'est pas
entendue leur parole n'est pas écouter
ce qui aboutit à telle scène et je vais
donner la parole à xavier iacovelli dans
un instant mais est-ce qu'il ya quand
même pas un risque d'effet boomerang
pour le président la république c'est a
dans un premier temps les études
d'opinion montrent plutôt une opinion
qui était favorable sur le fond aux
propos du des mâles macron mais pas sur
la forme on l'a vu dans les premiers
sondages est ce qu'il ya pas un rythme
fm moment notamment quand on voit cette
immense émoi moi je mets deux bémols à
ce que vous avez dit ya peut-être une
insuffisance gouvernementales et
peut-être que l'exécutif a pas bien tout
gérer de cette pandémie depuis deux ans
mais ce n'est pas la seule fois quand
même replacé le débat la france n'est
pas la seule à prendre des mesures
autoritaires ou des mesures restrictives
ya d'autres pays qui sont confrontés ils
n'ont pas tellement mieux gérer non plus
que nous vous regarder autour de nous en
europe et les confirmands qu'ont été
décrété c'est une privation de libertés
publiques on en a plutôt fait moins que
d'autres arnaud chez nous on nous
faisait signer des propre papier voilà
ça s'était plutôt plus qu'ailleurs mais
on est on est à l'exécutif une certaine
façon a fait des erreurs mais il n'est
pas le seul à l'avoir fait après sur les
violences dont on parle faut quand même
là encore en raison garder c'est une
partie
une minoritaire de la population on est
à 90 % de vacciner pour ça qu'on doit
tyranniser minoritaire mais on est on
est pas sur un mouvement d'opinion
général de ras-le-bol les français ont
plutôt été assez résilient mais assez
obéissant assez compréhensifs depuis
deux ans ils ont respecté les
confinements ils ont respecté le
couvre-feu ils ont respecté la pseudo
obligation vaccinale paraguay je me
posais la question tout à l'heure parce
que dire une obligation déguisée ce
qu'elle a reconnu d'ailleurs relevé en
disant c'est une forme d'obligation
déguisées ça me paraît très maladroit 6
obligatoire au même titre que la
diphtérie la pohjola nouveau cloud drive
est ce que vous êtes très contagieuse et
voilà est une maladie qui peut être
mortelle donc vacciner vous et puis sur
la violence le niveau de violence
verbale entraîne ne peut entraîner la
violence physique est là pour le coup
serait que le prix dans la république
avec sa volonté de faire un bon mot de
reprendre l'expression de pompidou et à
l'envers tiens je veux emmerder jusqu'au
bout les non-vaccinés c'est la stratégie
et puis d'être étant une certaine façon
un peu de sous citoyens par la suite
puisqu'il n'est qu'à partir du moment où
ils sont responsables ils sont plus
tellement citoyens moi ça me paraît être
une erreur parce que quand on est
président d présente tout le monde y
compris ceux qui pensent pas comme vous
y compris ceux qui ne font pas comme
vous xavier accueilli même si c'est un
débat qu'on a beaucoup à la semaine
dernière j'ai envie de vous entendre là
dessus surtout avec ces images je le
redis de violence à saint pierre et
miquelon
alors moi déjà je suis particulièrement
embêté et pas choquer mais en tout cas
ça ça m'embête vraiment que lorsqu'on
condamne les violences l'homme nous
opposants sont toujours sur le mais il
ya toujours un mais après la
condamnation des violences non il n'y a
pas d'excusé en fait aux violences
contre les élus ou même contre nos
institutions contre d'autres citoyens il
n'y a pas d'excusés
c'est un plateau excuse les violences la
question c'est est ce que le président
de la république a pas prise sur toute
façon à risque de récurrence au kaki et
là je ne sais pas si les avocats de la
france à son bisou du rassemblement
national mais en l'occurrence il a le
même des mêmes propos que les opposants
des différentes extrême en disant à
chaque fois le même et non la violence
n'est pas acceptable et ce n'est pas
parce qu'aujourd'hui on prive de liberté
à certains de nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens parce que il ya une
limitation de de liberté pour lutter
contre une épidémie contre nous pendait
niveau mondial effectivement ça ne
justifie pas la violence et sincèrement
moi j'en appelle aussi aux responsables
politiques en tout cas ceux qui se
disent responsables politiques d' éviter
d'appeler à cette mobilisation d'un but
d'éviter a appelé à ces manifestations
je vous rappelle qu'il ya quand même
notre collègue du sénat ce sénateur de
saint pierre et miquelon qui avait
appelé à cette mobilisation et qui a
abouti à l'agression de ce député et moi
je veux bien tout ce que vous voulez
mais enfin bon c'est pas des propos du
président qui ont entraîné les violences
je vous rappelle que les violences
contre les élus et notamment contre les
parlementaires de la majorité ont
commencé bien avant je vous rappelle que
notre collègue de l'assemblée nationale
qui a eu sa voiture et son garage brûlé
à quelques mètres d'eux de son de son
lieu d'habitation je ne suis pas sûr que
c'était par rapport aux propos du
président de la république sait donc pas
ce que j'ai dit mais y arrive il ya un
risque dans venus les débats je voudrais
donner la parole à m bringue art est ce
que vous êtes l'avocat du de la france
un sou mais absolument pas et
et moi j'ai écouté avec attention ce qui
est ce qui était dit et j'ai envie de
vous dire que c'est la démonstration des
raisons pour lesquelles aujourd'hui il
ya une crise de confiance aussi dans
l'appareil politique parce que
systématiquement plutôt que de parler d'
arguments juridiques factuel on vient
politiser le débat et on vient
évidemment essayer nous rentrer dans des
catégories politiques qui non seulement
n'ont pas lieu d'être et qui en plus est
face complètement le débat qui était
portée si vous avez bien écouté mon
propos évidemment que je condamne les
violences y ont été faites mais je pense
qu'il ya aussi une réflexion à avoir par
rapport à toute une frange de la
population qui non seulement ne sont pas
représentés et qui en plus précisément
peut être récupéré certains extrême à
des fins purement électoralistes et ça
c'est aussi un risque pour la démocratie
alors on va un petit peu rentrer dans le
détail vous redonner la parole
évidemment aux seins aux uns et aux
autres et je propose à steve jourdain de
nous rejoindre parce que on va parler
d'un dispositif qui est assez bon soir
thomas bonneau mieux bravo à d
à ces polémiques quand même sur sur ce
pass vaccinale sera examiné demain au
sénat c'est la question des contrôles
d'identité d'ailleurs olivier verrey on
a parlé aujourd'hui oui c'est l'un des
points qui va le plus faire débat sans
doute demain dans l'hémicycle le
contrôle d'identité les vérifications
d'identité la concordance d'identité
toutes ses nuances thomas bien c'est
peut-être un détail pour nous mais pour
les juristes ça veut dire beaucoup
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est de
renforcer la lutte contre la fraude dans
son viseur le recours aux faux-pas
sanitaires il y en aurait 190 mille
aujourd'hui en circulation annonce
d'oliver en tout à l'heure lors de son
audition au sénat et donc pour mettre un
frein à cette pratique il s'agit de
procéder désormais un contrôle
d'identité bien du détenteur du passous
du faux-pas sanitaires les conditions
sont précisées dans le texte qui sera
examiné demain le contrôle sera réalisé
lorsqu'il existe des raisons sérieuses
de penser que le document présenté n'est
pas authentique voilà ce que prévoit le
texte qui a été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière en gros
avant d'entrer au restaurant il faudra
désormais présenter son passé et se
tenir prêt à présenter éventuellement un
document d'identité six hauts
responsables du resto nous le demande
thomas et le sénat vieux
vous encadrer cette pratique oui c'est
une mesure qui inquiète en tout cas
beaucoup les sénateurs les élus
considèrent que le contrôle d'identité
est une prérogative exclusive de la
police et que déroger bien ce principe
serait tout simplement une violation de
nos libertés individuelles alors toute
la nuance porte sur les mots dont on
parlait tout à l'heure thomas le
gouvernement ne parle pas de contrôles
d'identité mais simplement de
concordance d'identité écoutez olivier
ferrand nous pensons que c'est important
de permettre à des personnes qui dirige
un établissement qui reçoit du public de
pouvoir n'ont pas contrôlé l'identité
mais vérifier la concordance entre
l'identité du pass et l'identité
figurant sur une pièce d'identité
haddock toutes ces questions là nous
nous en débattrons je rappelle que le
pass vaccinale ne s'appliquera pas pour
les établissements sanitaires et médico
sociaux c'était une évidence il ya pas
de directives nationales visant à
empêcher qui que ce soit de visiter des
proches qui seraient malades fragiles ou
encore moins en fin de vie voilà les
républicains ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
un thomas qu'ils allaient saisir le
conseil constitutionnel sur cette mesure
centrale du nouveau texte après le
parlement et la bataille politique
viendra peut-être le temps de la
bataille juridique thomas merci steve
réussira cité du michel berger dans un
sonic sur le laisser pour la nouvelle
année sur le post vaccinales merci 2e du
cadeau à toute heure dans notre zone
second débat évidemment je reviens
sérieux florence lassarade ce pourquoi
est-ce que ça vous inquiète ya cette
notion de contrôle d'identité comment tu
vas devoir s'en sont chargés moi je
voulais revenir sur l'histoire de la
violence mais tellement valises il
ya quelques temps j'ai posé une question
à gérald darmanin parce que mon maire
s'est fait assommer par départ des
mineurs de de 15 comme dans ce quinze
ans on m'a expliqué que c'était pas bien
grave qu'on pouvait pas mettre un
gendarme derrière chaque chaque enfant
de 13 ans quand il s'est agi de dupes à
cela tout le monde s'est affolé il y
avait tout d'un coup on se dit est ce qu
a pas finalement dans le pays ne
violence latente que peu va peut-être
exacerbé le pass vaccinale mais je pense
qu'il ya quand même il va même se font
là 2 alors moi je pense que si on veut
vacciner il faut de la bienveillance
c'est pas en agressant comment réussir à
convaincre bon je vous interromps là
dessus parce que ce sera le thème de
notre débat en seconde partie d'émission
mercredi les violences contre contre les
élus donc je passe là dessus mais je
reviens à la question des contrôles
d'identité votre point de vue là-dessus
qui doit s'en charger est ce que ça vous
inquiète
je vois pas très bien comment on peut
obliger un restaurateur on bichat déjà
contrôler les passes vaccinons je me
suis trouvé au restaurant avec quelques
quelques élus justement et et ce sont
quatre gendarmes qui sont venus visiter
vérifier et les passes et les cartes
d'identité mais comment le restaurateur
enfin c'est un peu délicat c'est un peu
délicat à moins qu'on puisse mettre à
moins qu'on puisse mettre la photo sur
le pass vaccinale ça peut être également
un rien déjà quand on paye par chèque au
restaurant ou ailleurs de demander des
papiers entité ou est ce que je veux
dire c'est pas oui oui enfin bon c'est
une démarche supplémentaire qu'on
demande aux restaurateurs pardon ils
doivent déjà le faire quand il sert de
l'alcool à des mineurs enfin pour
vérifier profiter quelqu'un n'est pas
mineure
oui mais enfin bon là c'est sûr sur la
sur la figure du mineur qui va dire
tiens celui-là est un peu jeune pour
pour boire de l'alcool voyez mes bons
choix sinon la carte d'identité mais oui
mais c'est la loi qui qu'il impose bien
c'est un peu différent bon mais c'est
peut-être que le post vaccinale est ce
que la loi imposera aussi chasser
d'accord avec mathieu là là là dessus je
fait que bon les restaurateurs ils l'ont
déjà fait bruno mes gars c'est pas de
train parce que c'est la question aussi
défaut parce vaccinaux qui se pose avec
des conséquences en termes de santé il
ya eu plusieurs cas malheureusement de
malades qui sont arrivés aux urgences ou
en réa est qui et qui avait un faux pas
ce bac signale et qui d'ailleurs n'ont
pas dit aux médecins est ce que c'est ce
qu'il ya un risque est ce que ça accroît
le risque ça oui vous avez raison en
fait il faut bien comprendre quelles
sont les conséquences d'être porteur
d'un poste d'un faux-pas sanitaire au
faux pas maximale dans la nature c'est
qu'en fait ces personnes non vaccinées
qui ne croit généralement pas à
l'existence de lakovic 19 fois sa
gravité ne crois pas du tout à
l'efficacité voire plutôt pense aux
dangers du vaccin en possession d'un
faux pas ce vaste plaque sinal ou
sanitaires vont avoir un mode de vie
comme les personnes vaccinées ces salles
point sexy à la limite on n'est pas
vacciné mais qu'on reste auto confiné
qu'on met en permanence le masque ffp2
et qu'on ne participe à aucune réunion
très bien à la nuit pourquoi pas mais le
problème ces personnes là vont utiliser
le faut parce sanitaires ou vaccinale
pour vivre comme tous les autres or
malheureusement ils sont inégaux inégaux
par rapport au virus est de plus en plus
nous voyons dans les rénovations ce que
j'appelle des clusters intrafamiliaux
c'était en fait le mari et la femme le
frère et la soeur parce qu'en fait
évidemment les antilles vers les
antilles vax se concentre maintenant sur
des résident d'aider des foyers
extrêmement minoritaire avec des
personnes qui s'auto mouvant les autres
de la dangerosité du vaccin et donc on
voit un patient hospitalisé dans un
service et son frère ou sa soeur dans un
autre service tous les deux dans un état
extrêmement grave effectivement on
découvre à ce moment là alors même que
parfois ils nous disent être vaccinés
finalement qu'ils ne le sont pas et
qu'ils sont peu qu'ils possèdent un
faux-pas sanitaires en fait il faut
savoir que le fait de posséder un pour 1
1 de clamer en fait qu on est vaccinés
alors qu'on l'ait pas et bien empêche si
on se présentait tôt à l'hôpital de
pouvoir éventuellement bénéficier de
thérapeutiques comme des anticorps
monoclonaux pour prévenir le risque
parce que si vous présentez tôt et vous
dit vous êtes vacciné on va dire
probablement vous ne risquez pas de
développer une forme grave de la maladie
et donc à l'inversé si vous êtes vacciné
ou peut vous proposer des thérapeutiques
pour prévenir ce risque mais de fait en
fait malgré tout il faut on peut
imaginer que les personnes qui sont qui
possèdent des faux-pas sanitaire ne
croyons pas la gravité de la maladie ne
se présenteront pas très cohérent à
l'hôpital en fait ils vont venir
généralement une fois qu'ils ont la
chance respiratoire aiguë en phase très
avancée à ce moment là il est vrai que
pour nous ça ne change pas la stratégie
thérapeutique bah ça on regarde c'est
j'entendais la chronique de steve tout à
l'heure la contrôle d'identité ou
concordance d'identité est ce que c'est
seulement de la sémantique qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière ça c'est déjà ça pose
des questions juridiques extrêmement
sérieuse épineuse parce que ça revient à
confier un pouvoir de police à des
personnes privées à des restaurateurs un
sombre d'acteurs de l'aspect civil mais
c'est ce qu'on disait ils ont déjà de
fait maison des mémés pour des règles
enfin pour des considérations notamment
pour les règles d'achats d'alcool à des
mineurs extérieurs qui sont très
particulières et qui ont pu d'ailleurs
être contrôlée par le conseil cantonal
est qui qui qui ne sont pas à mon avis
comparable parce que assurer non
seulement on vous demandez à des
restaurateurs qui ont déjà été prouvée
économiquement par la crise sanitaire
d'avoir une nouvelle prérogative qui
seraient liées au contrôle du pass et en
plus sur quel motif et sur quelles bases
factuelles vous allez pouvoir décider
que telle ou telle personne pourrait
présenter un faux-pas ce parce que c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que un débat
actuellement devant devant le sénat que
se pose la question de savoir quelles
sont les raisons sérieuses est-ce que
c'est du fascia c'est ce que vous allez
estimé que lorsque vous allez voir le
pass de telles personnes et bien il y
aurait pas de concordance entre son nom
et son visage je crois vraiment que ça
pose une question parce que c'est aussi
le risque d'arbitraire un risque
d'arbitraire dans l'ain détermination et
dans la définition des critères qui vont
permettre son contrôle alors ces
cellules l'un des thèmes qui sera abordé
dans les débats au sénat à partir de
demain il y en a un autre c'est la
question de l'âge parmi les amendements
qui sont annoncés demain
d'ailleurs je signale que vous pourrez
suivre ces débats en direct sur public
sénat on va laisser la place au débat
sur le post vaccinales demain en fin
d'après-midi alors ne pas parmi les
amendements qui sont annoncés il ya
cette idée de limiter le pass vaccinale
aux plus de 18 ans xavier iacovelli à un
moment qu'on vous a pas entendu est ce
que vous y êtes favorable à cette à
cette hypothèse
non je pense effectivement que le fait
de mettre à 16 ans et une à une quand ça
y est une raison qui est que entre 16 et
18 ans effectivement on a une activité
qui est beaucoup plus intense que que
moins de saison et donc je pense qu'il
faut considérer les plus de 16 ans les
lycéens comme des adultes et donc il
faut qu'on puisse avoir aussi se passe
ce pentax inhalent pour pour ces jeunes
adultes et donc c'est moi je ne voterai
pas tu 13 cet amendement qui eux qui
augmente l'âge de 16 à 18 ans et pour
parler encore une fois sur les contrôles
sur les contrôles et la possibilité ce
concours une fois ce n'est pas
contrairement à ce que dit mme allard à
porter ce n'est pas une obligation qui
est fait aux restaurateurs c'est une
possibilité de contrôler s'ils ont un
doute et c'est déjà le cas effectivement
quand vous l'avez dit sur le bateau
c'est déjà le cas quand on vend de
l'alcool les restaurateurs s'ils ont un
doute ils peuvent demander la pièce
d'identité aux consommateurs pour
s'assurer qu'ils ne sont pas mineurs
c'est le cas pour les ventes de
cigarettes également c'est le cas quand
on va dans un supermarché où la question
où le caissier que nous demander où nous
demandent régulièrement la pièce
d'identité pour justifier de la
concordance avec le chéquier par exemple
donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui on le
perd mais pour ça et aujourd'hui on le
propose effectivement pour le pass
vaccinale encore une fois dans une dans
un délai qui est court et en tout cas on
l'espère en tout cas cours et qui n'est
pas qui ne rentrera pas dans le droit
commun donc je vous rappelle que le pass
vaccinale n'est pas n'a pas vocation à
durer c'est pendant la prise là la crise
de sanitaires tiens d'ailleurs on peut
peut-être écouté valérie pécresse la
candidate lr à la in en ciel qui
justement s'exprimer sur cette question
c'était ce matin sur france info sur la
la la durée de vie de ce se passe
vaccinale on écoute valérie pécresse
le sénat souhaite que ce pass vaccinale
soit strictement réduit dans le temps
c'est à dire clairement que dès qu'on
aura un reflux de la pandémie il soit
supprimée et ce sera ma position si je
suis élue présidente de l'are stade il y
aura un critère à partir du moment où on
passerait un taux d'incidence en dessous
d'un tenancier dans son art est le passe
absolument et on est prêt à le remettre
au cas où ça repart
aujourd'hui on est vraisemblablement
dans le temps un pic pandémique divers
et vraisemblablement là encore je parle
avec beaucoup de guillemets
vraisemblablement on assistera à une
décrue au printemps donc que la
situation est celle là nous voulons un
pass vaccinale qu'ils soient strictement
limitées dans le temps nous voulons
protéger les français mais je ne veux
pas atteindre à leur liberté plus qu'il
n'est nécessaire
florence lassarade dans quel état
d'esprit seront les sénateurs elle est à
partir de demain est ce que vous avez
fait chanter de freiner le texte de le
ralentir c'est un peu l'état d'esprit
déjà au mois de juillet ce qu'on demande
c'est que le gouvernement vienne vienne
débattre viennent rencontrer les
sénateurs de nos parlements sa vraie
fonction c'est-à-dire cet échange qui
permet de voir ce qui est faisable ce
n'est pas faisable il me semble que le
peuple aurait quand même beaucoup plus
confiance s'il y avait des
échanges plus réguliers et quand il y en
a une en servent pas tous les textes
sont passés devant le parlement devant
l'assemblée le sénat alors après
les mesures il a fallu quand même qu'on
demande de devenir réexaminer les choses
au sénat je sais pas comment ça se passe
à l'assemblée nationale en tout cas au
sénat on a souvent l'impression
d'être là pour valoriser le gouvernement
pâle inverse je pense qu'on doit être
vraiment un lieu de débat et j'espère
que ça se passe en général ça se passe
pas trop mal au sénat les sénateurs sont
responsables et ils vont dans l'intérêt
général c'est pas c'est pas moi je suis
pas élu pour faire mousser tel ou tel je
suis pas je suis pas partisane et moi
dans mes dents mais dans ces questions
de santé qui sont d'abord médecin je
suis je suis d'abord médecin mais je
suis aussi élu et je veux faire remonter
quand même un peu ce qui le ressenti du
terrain
vincent bragarde pardon sur la question
peut-être que soulever valérie pécresse
et qui rejoint finalement ce que vous
disiez de pendant combien de temps on va
rester avec ces mesures telles qu'elles
ont été
rappelons le quand même à chaque fois
validé voté par par le parlement les
formes ont été respectées les formes ont
été respectées mais je crois que on a
une démocratie qui n'a pas appris des
précédentes crises on était habitué à
l'état d'urgence anti terroriste qui
avait été prononcée après les attentats
de novembre 2015 et on a vu les
difficultés que ça pouvait poser lorsque
les menaces peuvent s'inscrire dans le
temps et qu'on ne change pas les outils
de contrôle c'est à dire je le répète
c'est dans un premier temps il peut y
avoir des fils dérogatoires qui peuvent
s'imposer plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois pour faire face à une situation
d'urgence mais lorsque plus de deux ans
après l'apparition du risque sanitaire
on est toujours face à des textes qui
sont votées de façon accélérée la
procédure accélérée c'est l'idée que
finalement on ne permet pas
véritablement débat parlementaire et
pourtant il ya des arguments qui sont
des arguments tout à fait concret et qui
imposait d'ailleurs je veux dire que
toute la question ce qui était mentionné
tout à l'heure par rapport si je veux
dire aux effets en terme d'affichage de
la non suppose vaccinale peut-être qu'il
y aurait une meilleure adhésion aussi
répétées de vaccination si on permettait
un débat parlementaire réelle et s'il y
avait une totale transparence sur la
manière dont les mesures étaient vos
terres je vois que xavier iacovelli qui
demande
la parole depuis son bureau je vous la
donne est ce que les débats
parlementaires sont finalement
atténué par l'urgence brandi comme ça à
chaque fois par le gouvernement il
goûtait ça fait 21 mois qu on est en
situation de crise sanitaire en 21 mois
on a eu douze textes tous les textes
sont passés en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture au sénat puis en commission
mixte paritaire effectivement dans une
procédure accélérée mais sans jamais le
commence à avoir un déni de démocratie
et sans jamais interdire le débat et la
parole de l'opposition preuve en est
avec ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière on a des
semaines de contrôler régulièrement qui
nous permettent de contrôler le
gouvernement de faire des demandes de on
a des commissions dans la quête
franchement moi je veux bien tout ce que
vous voulez j'ai entendu effectivement
pas sur ce plateau en ajoie je rassure
mais j'ai entendu comme nous étions en
dictature que le parlement c'était un
déni de démocratie que le parlement
n'était pas représentatif et surtout
qu'ils n'étaient pas consulté et et
enfin franchement douze textes en 21
mois uniquement sur la question de
l'urgence sanitaire donc on peut pas
dire aujourd'hui mais moi je pense que
je me rappelle aussi c'est que lorsqu'on
a donné aussi la possibilité aux
sénateurs la dernière fois je me
rappelle d'une ceinture texte où on
avait les sénateurs aient l'air qui
avait voulu et irish beauté d'ailleurs
majoritairement pour la réouverture des
discothèques et la rouverture débat en
pleine pandémie en 2020 fin 2001 je me
rappelle également leur interdiction
pour le il avait voté un amendement pour
interdire le premier ministre de pouvoir
fermer les établissements recevant du
public justement en cas de crise ça pour
moi c'est de l'irresponsabilité
lorsqu'on a des responsables politiques
qui agissent comme ça on se dit que
heureusement qu'ils ne sont pas
aujourd'hui à la tête de notre pays
allez à bout de réponse pour conclure
florence lassarade puisque oui
largement moins ce que je demandais ce
qu'on a demandé aujourd'hui à olivier
ferrand c'est qu'ils viennent en
personne débattre parce que chaque
chaque sac séquence on le voit une
demi-heure et puis après il ya une
jeunesse à ses secrétaires d'état donc
qui viennent lui en personne débattre ça
sera très bien ça donnera une meilleure
image du du débat qui peut se passer au
parlement c'est parce qu'on a l'habitude
de voir depuis quelques mois ouais alors
il a annoncé je croise cet après midi
qui ne serait pas là demain me sera là
mercredi c'est ça bon écoute et on
suivra ça de près et en tout cas sur les
antennes de public sénat évidemment
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je rappelle vincent bragarde le
titre de votre livre revendiquons le
droit à la désobéissance est publié aux
éditions fayard merci à tous